do you like my thing is though is when
you're in that position because I find
myself in a similar position
um like would you because because
like who do you go to because everyone's
gonna come to you with their [ __ ]
everyone will come to you with their
problems it depends I only have a
certain a few people that I could really
go to like if you're having a bad day
who do you go to like who do you depends
on what kind of bad day I'm having right
sometimes I go to nobody sometimes I'm
just I deal with myself you know so off
the top of my head
um I know I could trust my therapist I
could go to her I could go to
JB for things I could go to make for
things I could go to jail for things you
know so I go to my big brother for
things
um I go to my mother for things you know
what I'm saying but overall it's like
I I feel like nobody really really
understand what I'm going through you
know what I'm saying so it's like a lot
of times I just keep it pushing you know
I mean to have a therapist it's nice
though and also to be great I mean
that's wonderful like I could tell her
anything you know what I'm saying like I
just tell her whatever you know what I'm
saying but I feel like
and it's crazy the more my life has like
picked up and expanded I don't it's
therapy is not the same if I'm not in
front of her like I can't do zooms and
yeah that [ __ ] don't work for me because
that's something that's like
since the pandemic people are doing this
yeah it's not the same it don't work I
gotta get in front of her you know what
I'm saying so it's like once the
pandemic hit I kind of feel back off
therapy a little bit right it's not the
same Zoom [ __ ] it's the same thing with
interviews I tell people I'll pass on
the zoom yeah yeah the zoom interviews
or whatever unless it's like you know
necessary yeah the necessity of it Gotta
Be You know but I'm like look I'd rather
wait till they're in LA and we have to
sit across from each other absolutely
because it's some more yeah at what
point in time because I do feel like
everybody should go to therapy everybody
I don't care who you are I don't care if
you ain't got I should definitely I
recommend everybody try it at least
everyone should try to have that outlet
where you could unapologetically just
express yourself in your room definitely
at least once how long have you been uh
going to therapy I've been going to
therapy since
2018. and that was by choice
Kinda Yeah it was by choice my lawyer
actually recommended it from me you know
what I'm saying I really I told my
lawyer you know I believe in honesty and
transparency you know so I was fighting
a gun case in Chicago that's it's behind
me now I remember yeah and I told my my
lawyer like I've never really not been a
fear of my life since I was 14 years old
crazy way to live 15 years old that's a
crazy way to wake up and live a lawyer
is a
uh he's uh over at he's 60 years old a
black man you know what I'm saying that
he I had two lawyers and I had a another
lawyer black woman she was in her 30s
you know 40s maybe and when I expressed
it to him they just refer like you need
to go to therapy and talk to somebody
you know what I'm saying and I did that
and within like my second third session
she literally went to court testified
for me or you know what I'm saying wrote
down and sent it to my my judge and I
was literally diagnosed with post
traumatic stress disorder